hello and welcome to this video plane
sit for like I keep forgetting who that
is good to bike at Yahoo pretty good
German international master so I'm
trying this line out again I don't score
well with it I think I have problems
handling then suing positions with them
I making that mistake why do I not start
with d3 again now it's not a big deal
but still I like it more than I'm a
little bit more flexible
okay so go here never take blunders Asia
life it's of course just a five-pointer
it's not the most crucial poem on the
whole board
I don't believe in compensation here for
black ok this is a tribe
so with him going for Bishop to g5 here
maybe I wonder if I should turn I go for
f4 hear something like f1
mf5 was my original idea and ticks and
then look h3 stuff like that can also go
look h3 immediately yeah this may be
better because where is he going Bishop
f6 is most active but then I have f5 f5
now okay wow I thought that that looks
pretty bad
okay maybe age for still
check
okay i forgot that be to hangs at the
end to be honest i was thinking i can
just stack like go go all the way to the
ending which is probably still true but
yeah i can i can go straight to the
ending its it's okay check
ending is very very good for what should
be winning actually because I can come
up to d5 and then I should be able to
win both DNC born
black resigns yeah yeah it cannot do
much against that plan okay so keep I
keep playing Knight f3 year which is
okay it cannot be a bad move but I like
to do this first and ask him about his
pawn structure because if he wants to
play this a five base setup he has to
almost has to play you five now because
they are not that many good waiting
moves and here I have additional options
like play with III 92 for example and I
like this more than an idea three base
cell so okay it's again it's not a big
deal okay so all this is fairly normal
and yeah II plate this is this yeah and
now I'm if he plays be five or something
mp5 is the best move I guess you should
be equal after be five I can try things
like that but I doubt that this is
anything special it's something it's
very often this kind of opening can lead
to a position where white is just very
very slightly more comfortable but it is
nothing particularly serious like here I
will probably end up with a position
where I'm a little bit better on the
queenside if you think about something
like this for example no I'm putting a
bit pressure here and yeah it's a it's a
little bit a little bit something um
yeah okay after that I think it's just
it's really just a pawn so II for
stopping any idea to activate this
Bishop yeah now it's one of those
moments yeah you either have to take on
g3 or allow why to play g4 and shut down
everything so he decided to take
yes sit it cannot be enough really yeah
i think f4 i believe was a good decision
not putting into a passive i'm playing
into a passive defense i think here i
just have the better points there in the
center okay the computer points out king
h1 and white wins winning is strong
Queen h2 + f5 10-8 it looks good of
course but is that so much worse I this
worse because there's this move I'm that
I didn't see I have this this one
you
yeah it looks like a clean porn at first
but the engine is not impressed it gives
this idea for counterplay if i move the
poem now here adds at least very
difficult mm-hmm okay so this happened
and now after f5 everything should be in
order yeah h4 was tougher now you know
like this one but of course it's it's
very nice for me check yeah now he has a
hard time to avoid this this ending
translation Sai p.m. he resigned not
much to do relief here cm taking this
and now I can just come up to the five
Jim it's stupid and I know something
like this it's just impossible to defend
the position like that yeah it's just
it's just over okay well thanks for
watching